[Music]
interview three years in v3 was my maths
interview of Jesus the last one I had to
do by firing away one of the most
terrifying experiences of my life
okay it wasn't backpack but mastered
that there my standpoint so the crack so
the questions they asked me I wasn't
going to copy first question that they
asked me in interview was something the
route of I I think the answer dialogue
when threatened neuropathy said if I was
to tell you the route of I is minus one
would you believe to which should I set
well you are a professor of math Oxford
so I'm going to say yes which play not
to is doing this problem the nuts and
bolts way or the clever ploy which were
brownie point nothing but way we take a
complex number Z equals to a real part
and an imaginary part you then it's set
say that route I that's terrible we then
say that route I is equal to that
complex number
square website and quote the real and
imaginary components we know the two a B
has to equal 1 + a squared minus psi X
equal nor 30 psi which that a equals B
equals for every routine the cover those
we're doing it is to use Euler's form
with one person which is basically the
connection a complex number which has
the real imaginary component in form e
to the I theta now the demography of
states that if you take the power of
that say e to the I and theta then you
just have cos n theta that I define and
bigger as I equals e to the I PI by 2
we don't believe me look at an Argand
diagram e to the I PI by 4 is going to
be equal to our half because just
multiply both sides by 1/2 which you can
then plug through and it gives you the
same result which is good because much
work I hands of God flops widgets is a
deductive transferred right now
especially the question asked me was for
what values of sine x equals KX all that
if K is any one solution only in the
first the positive x direction we're
going negative and again I might see not
too sure how you're supposed to answer
this but I think what he's supposed to
is have to graphically so yeah it's just
a line program tape then what you can do
is establish that well then you would
even get one solution in positive okay
if you set the gradient luckily it just
intercepts here could known a little
originality of buying last will in it so
you can take the gradient okay of
d-y-by-dx the peak is 1 and you know
that the distance in the X Direction is
to party plus pala tute certified I'll I
do so the limit in the positive K
Direction is going to be K between five
to five pi the negative direction anyway
you're going to get I want to be the
pitches intercept
bottom therefore K equals minus 0 3 pi
don't equipment up and want I show
tonight
the last question now community was to
establish
final 61 without even calculate if you
need now it kind of screen straight away
Taylor expansion because terrorist
faction is all about net taking
knowledge at one point and saying well
thing a grading the curvature and
and if they're just the more times you
have the more accurate your
approximation yet which is exactly what
I've done here I've just expanded it out
incidentally you need students and
raising scientific sign of progress rate
if you don't know a lot of ratings ready
he will student loan t see ya you just
you just expand out I don't need to
terms because it gives you a pretty
decent level accuracy any other thing I
need to point out is just at PI by 180
is equivalent to one degree total in
using magic of editing that works out as
Northpoint eight seven four which is
about life interview for this was my
last interview and it was my only
includes and Peter's which leads whether
they accept me so this has take place of
the physics interviewed amassing to me
and the general school at the same time
first question asked me was just like
first video I had wise to be physics
really didn't listen to my answer the
first physically question they asked me
this have to wait forms women towards
each other
computer string and they gave me was
actually six diagrams but I can't draw
so I thought I just do three I had to
pick out which ones would actually
happen in this case in case you're
wondering else's MZ the next question
that they asked me was lip ratchet which
essentially they just said to me
straight off calculus part of the winter
line with one edge wind early so I far
as the parameter distances ah being the
radius of the wind turbine V the speed
of the air which is fine plastic now we
see the speed of a wind turbine comes
from these kinetic energy of the air
coming in positive this is assuming 100
percent efficiency you can just add in a
terminal of the end point
but essentially what you want is to work
at account under the column of air per
unit time so I'm through the kinetic
energy is half MV squared the kinetic
energy of this column vector is half
robing zestiria pi squared
we team up in just the length of covered
please go ahead
we also per unit time as a cancel out of
T Rho PI R square V keep proper to the
next question I live on a Mac space one
is one of the weird question I think I
had one that is said to me what do you
never second derivative of function such
active works of curvature is the right
change of the gradient okay plot dy by
DX squared second derivative equals
minus y I don't know so we'll plot it
and the video that starts assuming it's
up or not and it just means that the
curvature is negative fitting a positive
Y so that's not where it should be
labeled love it's negative so positive
in a negative way so basically have
functionalists occur with all that it's
symmetric it's somehow very familiar
which makes sense in excited because to
let y equals sine X that you learn
quickly that dy by DX is correct
and the second derivative is minus sine
X so that's why and you know that's
implemented oscillator design recognize
and then they extended it what if it was
- 2001 in which case it just be very
frequent which then indicates an
operating system corresponds to the
frequency of the oscillation the last
question in the our community this
interview was if you're in room with n
people what value does n have to be led
to be the certainty of you finding
someone with your birthday in the room
search well there is no vote which as a
certainty because of the probability
holders is not my strong point what you
could say is that the probability is
equal to 1 minus the probability of
everybody in the room having a different
birthday to you
so probability knowing diversity one
party
350 for over three and fifty five
because the surrender spectacle other
dates to from it year at the end people
that's 3 6 4 3 6 5 to the N and the
probability of one person having the
same that they're due and 1 - 3 or 6
politics but again there was one more
questions but when I wrote out my
interview no I clearly got distracted
because my to be knows just stop there
was one more question icon allure is I'm
sorry I hope you found it useful please
comment below or send me a message if
you want to find out more or if you want
me to give you specific advice I've
helped our quality people find out some
getting pretty good at it I think and
yeah I love to hear from you I kind of
do this just because I want to help
people to get somehow that I know I
didn't have a first-hand account from
Oxford so I'm just trying to do that to
people but yeah I hope you go the world
and I wish you the very best with your
applications okay
[Music]